Musik Ich finde es auch gut, dass du direkt, als du ins Hotelzimmer reingegangen bist, dir die Schuhe ausgezogen hast. Es ist so ein Zwischending zwischen Sleepover-Party und Stand-Up, weil ich gerade stehe mit dem Mikrofon in der Hand und du so ganz eingekuschelt im Bettchen. Mit einem Doppelbettchen. Bist du eher der Wandschläfer oder eher der Fensterschläfer? Ich bin der Wandschläfer tatsächlich. Ich will immer so ganz eingeengt sein. Zwischen mir und meinen eigenen Emotionen und meinen eigenen Traumata will ich die Nacht verbringen, sodass ich mich möglichst nicht bewegen kann. Hast du einen festen Schlaf oder nicht? Also ich glaube, ich kann manchmal sehr schnell... Mir ist gerade ein, von dass mich die Antwort gar nicht interessiert. Bist du ein lauter Schläfer? Das interessiert mich eigentlich. Bist du ein lauter Schläfer oder bist du ein leiser Schläfer? Man kann ja auch mal akustisch ein paar akustische Experimente machen. Wir sind ja, sag mal, der Raum und Klang sind ja faszinierende Dinge. Also das ist ja mal... Wir haben ja auch so Richtmikrofone. Ich glaube, da kann man auch gut mit Leuten, jetzt mal den Leuten zeigen, wo wir hier eigentlich sind. Man kann das mal gut feststellen, wo wir gerade sind. Das sind hier die Vorhänge. Ich zeige euch mal die Wannen. Hier ist so eine Designerlampe, ich kann mal kurz... Herzlich willkommen zum Zweitsemesterveranstaltung der Sozialpädagogik-Fakultät. Wir machen heute unseren kleinen Klangausflug. Die Welt der Klänge heißt für dieses Semester unser Projekt. und ich möchte Sie einfach dazu einladen, jetzt mal die Augen zu schliessen und einfach mal sich darauf einzulassen, zu erleben, wie kann man einen Raum auch ohne Augen erleben und jetzt möchte ich Sie zu einem kleinen Experiment einladen. Dafür grüssen wir erstmal die Klasse, die Blindenklasse der Erich-Kästner-Realschule.
Da ist eine Stufe an der Tür, bitte stolper. Oh, jetzt, Magdalena, Entschuldigung, ich muss hier ganz kurz. Hier vorne haben wir Stacheldraht für ein Experiment. Oh nein, jetzt sehe ich die Melinda, hat sich verfangen. Von dem Holocaust, von der Ausstellung, der letzten Jahr im Holocaust-Ausstellung haben wir jetzt Leute diese ganzen Stacheln noch. Müssen wir kurz. Oh, Entschuldigung, jetzt, vielleicht wäre es ganz gut, Hanno, wenn du mal vielleicht dich einfach mal... Ach, draufle... Oh, shit! Das tut mir leid, jetzt... Also für alle, die jetzt noch da sind, also Katharina, wenn du vielleicht ganz kurz mal gucken kannst, wir haben ja den Gipskurs auch von... Ich kenne in der Zeit vielleicht schon mal kurz die Kissen. Dass wir hier vielleicht ein paar Kissen auslegen, falls die blinden Kinder noch mal stürzen, dass wir hier vielleicht ein paar Kissen haben. Also für alle, die jetzt noch da sind, Johann und Steffi, dass ihr vielleicht auch mal ganz kurz mitkommt und ich möchte einfach versuchen,
mit euch den Raum zu erleben. Macht einfach mal die Augen zu. Ich weiß, ihr seid blind,
aber macht einfach zur Not, zur Sicherheit einfach noch mal die Augen zu. Wir machen
auch kurz mal einen Sehtest, wie Thomas Gottschalk das immer gemacht hat. Merkt ihr da eigentlich
einen Unterschied, ob ihr Augen zu habt oder nicht? Ihr seid ja blind, aber ist es trotzdem
fürs Gefühl? Also binzelt ihr normal? Na? Ich sehe schon das Licht durch meine Augen. Also ist ein bisschen unangenehm, weil ich will mal sagen, dass ich blind bin, damit Leute mich respektieren als Blinden. Was heißt, du siehst Licht durch deine Augen? Ich sehe, ob es Tag ist oder Nacht ist, ob ich in einem dunklen Gebäude bin oder in einem hellen Gebäude. Das sehe ich schon. Bianca, wenn du vielleicht kurz mal die Flyer austeilst, ich habe da so einen Fragebogen vorbereitet, dass jeder auch seine Erfahrungen mit aufnehmen kann, mit protokollieren kann. Ich möchte es einfach mal ganz kurz euch einladen. Ich möchte ganz kurz nochmal aufmerksam machen, dass man bei Blinden immer den Test machen muss, wie Thomas Gottschweig mal vor Wetten, wo die Augen verbunden wurden, gemacht hat, dagegen hauen, so ein bisschen umzugucken, ist es wirklich ein Blinder? Wir hatten ja 2008 den Benedikt, nicht wahr, der war ja, der kam ja zu uns. Blindedikt. Blindi haben wir ihn auch genannt, blindes, dummes Arschloch haben wir ihn teilweise genannt, hat sich am Ende heraus erstellt, dass er tatsächlich die ganze Zeit taub war und nicht blind. Und eine Sonnenbrille aufhatte, sondern ein bisschen verwirrt, aber es war einfach nur ein cooler Typ, einfach nur so ein Catch-Race. Das haben wir oft das Problem, dass sie einfach coole Typen kommen und wir einfach annehmen, sie sind blind und dann, nun ja. Wie Lana doch cool und blind auch beieinander liegt. Richtig, ja. Das ist nicht immer wieder neu. Wir hatten Lana Del Rey zum Beispiel da, sehr coole Frau, die hatten wir drei Tage hier in Behandlung und. Nicht blind. Die war auch nicht blind, nee, auch nicht doof, also ganz nette junge Dame. Jetzt möchte ich sie mal ganz kurz einladen, Bianca und Caroline, wenn ihr einfach vielleicht mal kommen wollt, einfach mal die Augen zumachen und einfach mal gucken, wie verändert sich der Raum. Der Klaus und ich, wir stimmen jetzt beide einen Ton an und wir sagen E in einem gewissen Ton, wir synchronisieren den Ton und dann bewege ich mich im Raum und ich lasse mein Mikrofon, meinen Tonkolben schwenke ich sanft durch den Raum.
Schleiche ich dir manchmal ins Gesicht, mein Tonkolben, guck mal was passiert.
Auch wenn wir jetzt in unserem Schlafzimmer sind gerade, passt das gar nicht.
Also wir stimmen mal an. Hamburg, mach mit. Jetzt die Dusche. Kommst du bitte aus meinem Badzimmer raus, ich möchte nicht jetzt wieder rein, komm bitte wieder rein. Erleben Sie den Klang, ich möchte mal ganz kurz, also Melanie, was hast du jetzt, was hast du gefühlt, hast du eine Veränderung entdeckt oder wie war es bei dir? Ich muss sagen, der Raum hat so etwas ganz Haptisches, so etwas ganz Fundamentales. Ja, sehr gut, Melanie. Sie geht da nochmal näher drauf ein, Melanie. So etwas habe ich noch nie gesehen, Entschuldigung, so etwas habe ich noch nie wahrgenommen. Ich bin ganz erstaunt, was der Raum dann doch auch für unterschiedliche Klänge aufweist, je nachdem, wo man sich gerade befindet. Ich gehe jetzt nochmal hier in die Ecke des Raums und man merkt schon, hier ist eine andere Akustik. Akustik. Auch interessant, der Fernseher, in Hotelzimmern auch immer ein Punkt. Also, bist du so ein Typ auch, der dann immer ins Hotelzimmer geht, erstmal die Glotze anmacht?
Die Glotze, wie wir im Ruppert sagen, ne? Machst du auch immer an?
Ja.
Ohne Scheiß. Woh, ich habe nichts getan.
Für 39 Cent die Minute mittlerweile? Das ist ja rapid nach unten gegangen, der Preis.
Haben wir nicht 39 Freicent oder so? Ach komm, das ist ja jetzt Radio-Nukularniveau, das wir hier anrufen. Ja, jetzt sind wir gerade auf dem Hotelzimmer und wollen tatsächlich jetzt darüber reden, was morgen passiert. Am morgigen Tage moderieren wir beiden Chaoten, die Vollhongs, die ihr noch kennt von damals. Wir beiden Krie gerade mitten in der Nacht einfach durch die Hotelzüberschreien, weil wir es kennen. Und weil es sich eine Scheisse am Arsch umgegeben sollte. Wir beide bei Moin Moin, wenn das nicht mal wirklich crazy wird, dann weiß ich aber auch nicht. Das wird unfassbar. Wir machen morgen Moin Moin, die all das beliebtige Radioshow. Aber hä, machen wir einfach nur eine langweilige Morgenshow, wo wir halb motiviert User-Kommentare vorlesen und nebenbei einen Croissant mampfen? Oh, danke, dass du fragst. Ja, genau das haben wir vor. War ja vom Timing her jetzt nicht ideal. Vom Timing meinst du? Ja, ich wusste nicht, dass du in die gleiche Richtung gehst. Auch wieder so ein Fall, wo ich dir nicht vertraut habe. Ich dachte, du gehst in eine andere Richtung. Deswegen habe ich die Pointe vorgezogen und habe sie schneller gemacht, was... Komplett vergessen, ich habe komplett ausgebildet, was du gerade gesagt hast. Es wird gerade Werbung gemacht für eine G20-Gipfel in Turkey, ob ich das verstanden habe oder nicht. Es klang so, als wäre es die Werbung für eine G20-Gipfel, was ich nicht verstehe. Warum musst du da Werbung für gemacht? Also ganz kurz, wir haben ja morgen mehrere Möglichkeiten, an die Sache heranzugehen. Wir können uns ja erstmal einfach, also die Leute werden uns ja zu grossen Teilen nicht kennen, mich vielleicht mehr, weil ich schon mal bei Rocket Beans war, bei Almost Daily und bei Bonjour. Dich würden wahrscheinlich die wenigsten kennen. Das ist auch meine Angst, dass das negativ aufgenommen wird, dass es heißt, oh, darf denn jetzt jeder Moin Moin moderieren. Was ist eigentlich los? Aber finde ich interessant, dass nicht du, wenn du bei Moin Moin moderierst, dass nicht du sagst, oh, was für eine Ehre Moin Moin zu moderieren, sondern dass du sagst, ja, darf denn jetzt schon jeder Depp Moin Moin moderieren, wenn ich es moderieren darf. Es sagt viel über dein Selbstbewusstsein aus. Wir haben ja heute auch über dein Selbstbewusstsein gesprochen. Über deins auch, wir haben über unser Selbstbewusstsein gesprochen. Wir haben unser Selbstbewusstsein gesprochen und so über gemeinsames Selbstbewusstsein. Und du hast ja heute eine Zugfahrt getätigt und hast lange über dich nachgedacht und ich fand es schön, dass du tatsächlich auch zu einem Fazit gekommen bist. Man denkt ja manchmal so vor sich hin und klar ist dein Handy aus der Tasche gefallen und du hast tatsächlich das Fazit gezogen, dass du zu wenig Selbstbewusstsein hast. Wie hat sich das im Laufe des Tages geändert? Dass ich für meine Ziele, die ich habe, zu wenig Selbstbewusstsein habe, was okay ist, was man sich auch erarbeitet, was man sich auch durch Community erarbeitet, haben wir schon in den letzten Podcasts ein bisschen häufiger darüber gesprochen. Was hast du denn für Ziele? Mit einem Raumschiff zum Mars zu fahren, fliegen. Und nach genauem Studium des Weltalls habe ich diesen Wunsch revidiert und habe aus dem Mars fahren zum Mars fliegen gemacht. Ja, deswegen die Frage, wie gehen wir da morgen ran? Wir können uns ja erstmal direkt das einfach machen und uns bei den Zuschauern einschleimen, so, oh Rocket Beans, ihr habt die beste Community der Welt, es ist für uns so eine grosse Ehre, hier sein zu dürfen. Ich würde auch gerne altmodisch moderativ daran gehen, so, herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Einschalten dieses Senders, gute Wahl und guten Morgen! Das ist so ein bisschen auch, ich finde auch dieses Sprechdring, was ich belegt habe, das spricht so ein bisschen für altmodisches Moderieren direkt. Es macht einen direkt zu so einem altmodischen, so 80er Jahre Moderator. Aber ist es denn zu Recht altmodisch? Guten Morgen zur Wahl dieses Fernsehsenders, herzlichen Glückwunsch, wir begrüssen Sie, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und das ist Florentin Will. und wir haben lauter Gäste, die sich andere nur erträumen, überhaupt mal zu treffen, und wir haben keinen Erfolg und kein Selbstbewusstsein, aber wir sind so schlecht. So den ganzen Tag, glaube ich, haben die Leute keinen Bock drauf. Die wollen aufgepeitscht werden, die wollen aufstehen, die sind mit einem Bein noch im Bett und brauchen uns. Wie diese nervigen Morgen-Shows von Morning-Shows von Radios, die kommen mit Hey, hey, guten Morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgen, morgenü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-t You guys. Immer so, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, nö, ha, ha, you guys.
Und das finde ich wichtig, dass wir die Personen morgen auch dabei haben, die einfach nach jedem Gag, na und Stefan Tietze, Tietze, you guys.
So crazy.
Und noch besser, wenn wir alle beide diese Figuren, drei Figuren, in und zwei einer und dann die ganze Zeit immer so der Bildung um uns werfen und niemand mehr versteht, was vorne und unten ist.
Anstatt dass zwei Leute durcheinander reden, reden sechs Personen einfach durcheinander. You guys! No, wow! Hey, und ich weiss nicht was, wo ist es morgen? Hey, hey, hey, boboboboboing! You guys! Grossartig! Also Morningshow ist tatsächlich ein Genre, dem ich mich noch nie gewidmet habe. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie aktiv Morningshow geschaut und auch noch nie produziert. Und ich weiss nicht genau, wie es dir geht, aber ich habe morgen so eine ganze so eine straue Stimme. Sag ich mal, hallo ihr Süssen, was macht ihr denn schon von den Empfangsgeräten daheim? Aber habt ihr noch ein bisschen Schlaf in den Augen? Oh, reisen Sie euch mal raus, wir wollen euch den Schlaf aus den Augen reiben. Und hier kommt ein Song von Nelly Futado. Flames to dust. Man muss ja Morning Show auch ein bisschen in grosse Anführungszeichen setzen, weil es ist um elf, zehn uhr dreissig. Da machen die meisten Leute Mittagspause einfach. Stimmt, das ist eigentlich eine Regenlashow. Naja, also. Bisschen übertreiben. Exaggeration. Warte mal, lass mich mal kurz auf den Balkon gehen. Balkon. Aber das sind dann so die Momente auf Partys, wo man sich eine Zigarette anmacht. Genau, wo man sich eine Zigarette draußen macht, wo man lernt, ach hast du ein Feuer und so und dann draußen so, und dann draußen innen pocht der Beat irgendwie der Pizza-Gro. Den kennt sie alle, die Sprüche der Raucher, hast du ein Feuer. Was, um an Feuer kurz, und man steht hier draussen und natürlich, klar, Hanna ist auch da und man, hey, na, okay, ich habe dich ja vorhin gesehen, du bist eine Freundin von Steffi oder wie, und ja, ja, ich studiere jetzt auch Politik und Wissenschaften. Ah ja, okay, cool. Ja, Politik hat mich auch immer sehr interessiert.
Das Gespräch hat ihm überhaupt keine Interesse. Ja, aber so lernst du Leute kennen, deswegen lernen wir keine Leute kennen, weil wir keinen Bock auf diese Smalltalk-Partyschein haben. Oder das wäre einfach, weil uns andere Leute nicht so interessieren wie wir selber. Ja, ich rede lieber mit mir selbst als mit Hannah, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Also jetzt, Hannah ist auch eine dumme Fotze, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, aber klar. Wer war der Erste, der gesagt hat, hast du eigentlich Feuer? Weil diese Abkürzung macht
natürlich wesentlich dramatischer, wesentlich gefährlicher, was eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache ist. Nur Instinkt wird da so Feuer, Feuer, Feuer, ja, ui. Du bist jetzt gerade in deinen indogenen Stammesslang zurückgefallen, hui, hui, hui, zurückgefallen. Das wird auch immer geil, wenn man so ganz im Gehirn so uralte Erinnerungen an so Stammessprache oder so plötzlich einfach kommt und so hui hui hui hui. Ich finde das ganz geil. Die Beatles haben mal auf dem Dach gespielt. Das ist ja gerade der Moment, wo wir am Balkon einen Podcast aufnehmen. Irgendwann werden Leute, werden da so diese Doppelbeckerbusse, wo dann irgendwie man aufs Ohr bekommt. Und jetzt hier rechts sehen Sie das Gebäude, wo 2015 das Podcast-Uvo zum ersten Mal eine Outdoor-Version aufgenommen hat. Da oben. Da oben? Sehen Sie den falschen Balkon fotografieren, weil es nicht genau so spät kommt. Richtig, aber die Insider wissen, hey, das ist gar nicht der echte Balkon. Aber die Insider fahren nicht mit diesen Bussen. Aber wir können es ja mal sagen, wir sind hier im Hotel, wir wissen nicht, wie es heißt, aber Hotel 505, Nummer 505 geht vielleicht genau wie 404, was ja schon eine sehr erfolgreiche Zahl ist, als legendäre Zahl. Aber 505 geht vielleicht in die Geschichte ein, auch als legendäre Zahl für das Hotelzimmer, an dem eine weitere Schicksalsnacht stattgefunden hat, denn Stefan und ich werden heute miteinander schlafen. Ja. Das erste Mal. Ich bin das erste Mal mit jemandem haben, der mir sehr bedeutete. Und einfach während dem Podcast einfach. Ja, nicht irgendwie, es sollte etwas Besonderes sein, genau. Da dachte ich mir, komm, machst du mit dem Mann und zweitens einfach mal während du einen Podcast aufnimmst. Aber bist du ein bisschen aufgeregt, hast du Performance-Ängste oder so? Ja, in der Tat, ich habe immer diese Ablieferangst. Dass du zu früh ablieferst, oder? Ja, genau. Ob ich jetzt im übertragenen Sinne, ob ich zu früh abliefer, ob ich zu spät abliefer. Das ist schlimmer eigentlich. Ob ich nicht in Ablieferstimmung komme, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Und du weißt auch nicht, wie du da so drauf, was du so willst, also was deine Abliefervorlieben sind. Ich versuche dir das immer zu zeigen während dem Akt. Mit Blicken. Mit Blicken und auch ich versuche deinen Körper so ein bisschen, es ist ja ein Tanz, ich versuche dich auch so ein bisschen zu führen. Ist Sex wie ein Tanz für dich? Im Endeffekt schon, ich trete ständig auf die Füsse und ich habe meine Schuhe vergrübt. Da könnte man so viel draus machen! Danke! Und deswegen vertraue ich den nicht. Und im Hintergrund läuft Nelly Fortale, kann man auch wieder, wem schon mal, aber nur sowas in der Art, nur als Angebot. Nee, ich finde Sex ist wie Mario Kart. Man schüttelt so lange am Nunchuk, bis man driftet, bis man in die...
Ach fuck, ey, ist aber auch schon spät.
Freundschaft ist wie Mario Kart, man ist wahnsinnig schnell, es werden Pilze verteilt und Wario ist dabei.
Gibt's den? Schon? Also viel finde ich den ganz gut.
Das kannst du rausschneiden.
Ganz kurz.
Aber ich glaube, Pilze verteilt nicht.
Ich glaube, das war mein... Finde ich ganz gut, finde ich ganz guter Gag. Bananen eingeführt, vielleicht, nein, keine Chance. Ganz kurz, kennst du dich mit Hamburg aus? Ich kenne mich in Hamburg überhaupt nicht aus. Ich war hier einmal mit Freunden, habe ein Wochenende verbracht, da haben wir einen Affen... Ja gut, dann stell dir keine Fragen, wenn ich die Antwort nicht interessiert, dummes Arsch. Mit Freunden hier, die Leichtfreude, mit denen du immer Pokémon durchzockst? Ja genau, da hatte einer Geburtstag und wir sind immer schön auf die Reeperbahn gefahren, du, die Stahlfibrisse!
Ja, wir sind auf der Reeperbahn tatsächlich, aber die Reeperbahn ist ja wahnsinnig lang, ne?
Also es gibt ja Reeperbahn, dieses Rotlichtviertel legendär.
Sonst wär's der Reeperweg.
Wir sind jetzt auch auf Reeperbahn, aber anscheinend in den zivilisierteren Gegenden.
Und ich lasse einfach mal mein Mikrofon hier so ein bisschen den Balkon herunter an dem langen Kahn.
Oh Gott, das wird so abfallen. Und es ist geklaut, das Mikrofon ist geklaut. Weil ich bin mir da gerade nicht so sicher. Man sieht hier nämlich, es wird so abfallen, ohne Scheiss. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es geschafft habe, den Hamburger Flair ein bisschen einzufangen, indem ich das Mikrofon an Kabel durch die Luft gewirbelt habe. Wirbel! Du hast den Hamburger Flair nicht eingefangen, aber eine alte Frau, eine alte Pennerin, die da unten kurz aufgeschmiert hat. Echte Pennerin. Aber siehst du mal, wir sind das einzige Hotelzimmer, ausser das neben uns, das einen Balkon hat. Ansonsten hat niemand einen Balkon, auch unter uns hat niemand einen Balkon. Auch dein Zimmer. Das stimmt, ich bin in 506 und du kannst hier in mein Bett reinschauen. Ja, wir schlafen im gleichen Bett, du Affe. Ja, stimmt, sorry. Aber ganz kurz, wie gesagt, ich wollte dich fragen, ob du Hamburg kennst, weil man sieht hier ja relativ viel von Hamburg. Also man sieht relativ viel, da hinten ist der Alex, glaube ich. Da ist der Dom, haben wir auf jeden Fall, da hinten. Das ist das Brandenburger Tor. Genau, und die Golden Gate Bridge, glaube ich, ist da hinten. Und da, wo du die ganzen Lichter siehst, ist die Freiheitsschadung, da war die französische Revolution, fand da statt. Da war die Guillotine. Die grosse Guillotine, halten viele für einen Hackebeil, aber es war eigentlich eine tropische Frucht. 10.000 Meter hoher Turm, der gebaut wurde. Zwei verschiedene, deswegen vertrauen wir uns nicht, weil wir immer versuchen, andere Wege zu gehen. Man weiss auch nicht, welcher der bessere ist. Nee, das ist ja das Problem mit Wegen. Du musst ja auf den Weg gehen. Und Wagen. Siehst du, führt das jetzt irgendwo hin mit der Waage? Aber ich wollte sagen, das Problem an
Wegen ist, dass du ja erst noch nicht weisst, wo es hingeht, wenn du den Weg betrittst. Das ist so eine
Sache, das ist mir auch sehr gut. Und wir gehen ja mal zwei unterschiedliche Wege, die sich ja manchmal
kreuzen, aber vielleicht sollten wir einfach mal auf der gleichen Allee gehen, mit rechts und links Gästen. Was ist für dich die perfekte Metapher, das perfekte Bild für eine perfekte Freundschaft? Ist es nebeneinander einen Weg gehen, Hand in Hand gehen, sich gegenseitig tragen, sich mal kurz unterstützen oder was ist für dich die perfekte Metapher? Es ist mehr so ein Abseilen, so ein Rockclimbing, wo man auch mal den anderen hochziehen muss. Man sichert sich gegenseitig, gibt sich Halt und kommt langsamer voran insgesamt. Man kommt sehr langsam voran, das ist auch fürs Leben, man kommt nicht so schnell voran. Und man weiss auch nicht, ob man auf dem Berg wirklich will oder ob es nicht einfach eine Seilbahnmöglichkeit ist. Ja, irgendwann kommt man an so einen Punkt, wo man dann irgendwie merkt, es ist scheisse kalt und nur einer von uns kann überleben. Ich muss den anderen gegebenenfalls aufessen. Ich finde das relativ gut. Also man hat auch begrenzt Sachen zu essen, man hat nicht viel Geld. Man macht nebenbei vielleicht einen Podcast, der auch nicht so gut läuft. Ich meine, ich weiß auch nicht, wo das zu... Okay. Ja, vielen Dank Stefan Hitzow für diesen kleinen Einblick in deine Besuche. Aber auch so ein Bild, das immer schön ist, wir haben gegenüber von uns eine grosse Häuserfront, wo alle Fenster dunkel sind, bis auf ein einziges Fenster. Und da kommt bei mir natürlich der Geschichtenerzähler sofort hoch. Was ist in diesem Fenster gerade? Was geht da gerade vor sich? Es sind da vielleicht zwei andere Podcaster, zwei Frauen vielleicht, die gerade auch einen Podcast aufnehmen. Radio Nucular, die nebenbei auch einen Podcast aufnehmen. Aber das. Aber das ist ein guter sein, zwei Frauen, die Podcast aufnehmen. Genau. Und dann plötzlich begeht ein bisschen was von Lucky Number Sleffin gerade, die sind genau die Gebäude, die genau gegenüber voneinander stehen. Und dann könnten wir so die Kabel rüberwerfen und dann könnten wir, ja genau, dann haben wir die Mikrofone der jeweils anderen und sagen ihnen eine geheime Botschaft. Die sie erst merken am nächsten Podcast. Im Podcast dann. Genau, und dann sagen wir ihnen was drauf und dann werfen wir die Mikrofone wieder zurück. Und dann merken sie, dass du einen dummen Peniswitz gemacht hast und ich dich zweimal unterbrochen habe. Und sie haben irgendwie ganz romantische Sachen da reingesäuselt. I love you, gesagt. Ja. Weil es sind Engländerinnen. Ich habe die Geschichte ein bisschen weitergedacht in meinem Kopf. Okay, das ist gut. Also ich sehe Freundschaft wie so dieses Spiel, wo man, wo der andere so vorgekündigt. Wie das Spiel des Lebens. Lebens. Eine sehr naheliegende Mitarbeiter. Also das Leben ist für mich wie das Spiel des Lebens so ein bisschen. Aber da habe ich mal, wollte ich mal einen Tweet machen. Das Leben ist wie Spiel des Lebens, bei der Hälfte der Zeit fehlen schon die Hälfte der Teile und irgendwie sowas, aber du hast sofort, nee, der Hund hat die Hälfte der Teile gefressen. Genau, das Leben ist wie ein Spiel des Lebens, der Hund hat die Hälfte der Teile gefressen. Irgendwie sowas, glaube ich. Ich finde den ersten Satz schon gut, also das Spiel ist wie das Spiel des Lebens. Das Leben ist wie das Spiel des Lebens. Und du kennst doch dieses Spiel, was man als Kind gespielt hat, wo einer vor dir kniet und du nimmst dann den Kopf von dem anderen und dann hast du so langsam, machst du deine Hose auf und dann springst du so über den anderen drüber und dann gehst du in die Hocke und dann springt der Erste wieder über dich drüber. Das ist für mich Freundschaft. Auch mal vor dem anderen auf die Knie gehen und ihm erlauben, den nächsten Schritt zu geben mit dem Wissen, er geht auch gleich wieder in die Knie und ich kann über ihn drüber springen. Und so kommt man immer weiter und weiter und muss sich immer abwechselnd einander aufopfern. Das ist für mich das Richtige. Ja, das stimmt. Ist auch eine gute Beziehung, ist auch so. Das ist abwechselnd geben und nehmen, mit dem Vertrauen, ah, ich weiss, dass ich jetzt gebe, kann aber auch gleich wieder nehmen.
So. Ich glaube, da ist gerade jemand mit dem Messer gewesen, bin mir nicht so sicher.
An der Schafsseite.
Wenn wir jetzt irgendwie so einen Mord irgendwie sehen, quirten oder sowas. Auch die, die Weten ist hier mal einzufangen, man denkt ja immer, Stadt ist hauptsächlich von Menschen bevölkert, aber ... Kur-ra-ra-lam-lam-lam-mananana-mananana-nyeeeu, der vorbeirasende Wal darf natürlich nicht fehlen bei uns.
Ein Freund des Podcasts, das Zebra.
Oh, da haben wir einen Langschwanzspeisling. Wir hören mal hin, sein charakteristischer Balzhof. Er ist gerade auf der Suche nach einer Partnerin. Ganz prägnant hört man ihn. Die fruchtbaren Partnerinnen erkennt man am charakteristischen Geräusch. Und es ist so, dass wenn das Männchen bereit zur Paarung ist, so ergänzt er … Da hatten wir es gerade! Das ist ein ganz seltenes Schauspiel, liebe Freunde, der Ornithologie. Wir haben hier ein ganz spezielles Falspiel.
Und tatsächlich, jetzt!
Oh mein Gott!
Er zieht die... er hat die Socken noch an! Er zieht die Hose aus!
Er lässt die Socken an!
Und jetzt der charakteristische Ruf des Sperlings. Leider ist es heute nichts gewesen. Das Pärchen hat sich nicht gefunden. Vielleicht in einem nächsten Mal. Wenn es wieder heißt, wildes Leben in Hamburg. Ja, meine Füsse werden langsam richtig kalt. Du hast es schon richtig gemacht. Ich habe mich gefragt, warum denn der Stefan, der Dussel, warum bleibt er denn im Hotelzimmer stehen, so zwischen Tür und Angel? Aber tatsächlich hast du es richtig verstanden. Ich bin hier draußen mit Hannah. Zwischen Tür und Angel, ganz kurz. Wir Sprichwortfreaks, wir. Zwischen Tür und Angel. Man sagt ja auch, wenn eine Tür ganz weit offen ist, dann ist die Sperrangel weit offen. Und ich dachte immer, dass es heisst, dass man eine ganze Angelroute so spannen kann,
dass sie so weit offen ist, dass man eine ganze Angelroute, weil ich habe nie gerafft, was Angel sein soll.
Oh, die ersten Jazz-Cats kommen, die ersten Jazz-Katzen kommen die Strasse entlang.
Das ist der Hamburger Jazz, der berühmte Hamburger Jazz. Wir fangen ihn kurz ein.
Aber er zieht auch schon weiter.
Und der nächste kommt schon wieder. Glaubst du, das wird heute noch was mit Bianca und Carla? Das Licht drüben ist ausgegangen. Keine Chance. Mit den Ferngläsern drüben. Die sind ja ganz süss, aber was machen sie jetzt? Jesus. Was in diesem Haus da drüben? Was geht da eigentlich alles los? Wir haben tatsächlich Richtmikrofone, das heisst, die Mikrofone nehmen in einer geraden Linie vorneweg auf. Also nicht wie unsere normalen Podcastmikrofone. Wir hören bis ins Hall, können wir sogar reinhören. Ja, das heisst, wenn wir dieses Mikrofon jetzt auf das Fenster richten, könnten wir theoretisch hören, was dort geredet wird. Wir können es aber selber nicht hören, weil es ja aufgenommen wird, aber ihr könnt es hören, was jetzt gleich ihr hört. In drei, zwei, eins. Also, ich finde ihn ja eigentlich schon ganz nett, aber ist er nicht ein bisschen gross? Und warum? Der andere, der sieht so aus, als hätte er ganz viel abgenommen, in ganz kurzer Zeit. Aber jetzt hängt ihm das ganze Gesicht so runter und jetzt hat er wieder zugenommen. Jetzt hat er wieder ein bisschen zugenommen. Warum hat er wieder zugenommen? Was ist da passiert? Ich weiß nicht, ich mag es genau nicht so. Das sind meine Typen. Guck mal, mach mal das Licht aus. Aber was steht da auf seinem T-Shirt? Warum hat er Rocket Beans? Ich kenne die nicht. Was lustiges. Schöne es nicht. Klassisches, klassisches Improf.
Was ist lustig?
Was ist das?
Ich denke, es sind Improf-Künstler, die sagen, ein anderes Ding, ding dong, hallo, ich
komme für das Steuer.
Nee, was ist lustig?
Das ist nicht gut.
Nein, das kann ich nicht.
Okay, wir werden auch jetzt selber beobachtet.
Das ist nicht schlecht, wir singen jetzt mal relativ laut.
Ich will nämlich einmal den Anruf bekommen von der Rezeption, dass wir auf dem Lied die fucking Fresse halten sollen.
I wanna be a part of it, New York, New York.
Das ist so schwer zu singen, ey. In the jungle, the mighty jungle, the lion sleeps tonight.
Ah, we, we are bumblewee.
We, we are! Das Podcast UFO, das Podcast UFO ist auf einem Balkon. Das Podcast UFO, das Podcast UFO wird gleich angeschwärzt von der Rezeption. Hau im Mauer, hau im Mauer, hau im Mauer, hau im Mauer, hau im Mauer, hau im Mauer, hau im Mauer. Wir brauchen eigentlich so eine Loop-Machine, wo man das dann immer so lupen könnte. Das ist nicht schlecht. Loop-Machine. Loop-Machine. Ah, geil! Ach, das schiedet sich. Das sind diese Abende, glaube ich, an die man oft zurückdenkt und sagt. Glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, man denkt ... Warte! Und im besten Moment so nicht ... Lass es mich erklären. Ich glaube, man denkt nie an Abende zurück, an denen man gesagt hat, ich glaube, wir denken an den Abend zurück. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Ding. Man kann sich solche Momente nicht bauen. Man kann sie nicht kaputt machen, indem man sagt, es wird der Abend, an den wir uns zurückdenken. Ja, das stimmt. So habe ich schon vielen Leuten, schon vielen sehr verstörten Frauen eine Erinnerung fürs Leben genannt, wo sie sich dann vor Gericht auch nicht mehr daran erinnern konnten, was recht gut war für mich tatsächlich. Aber die Roofies waren halt nicht schlecht, waren nicht billig. Nee, weil ich bin so ein bisschen aufgeregt, aber so ein bisschen freudig auch auf morgen. Ich bin gespannt, wohin führt das? Ich glaube, es wird ein riesiges Desaster, es wird das zweite Basel-Saster. Ich glaube, wir haben einfach kein Glück mit solchen Ausflügen irgendwie, weiss nicht. Heute hat es ganz gut geklappt bis jetzt, aber ich glaube, isst du die Pizza eigentlich noch? Ja, auf gar keinen Fall. Echt nicht, dann will ich noch ein Stück. Komm, wir gehen mal wieder rein. Das Zimmer kühlt sich auch auf, das will ich nicht. Das ist so ein aufkühltes Zimmer. Nee, ich kann nicht mehr ein bisschen wärmen heute. Da habe ich schon mal erwähnt, dass ich sehr viel Schlaf brauche und wir morgen eine Morningshow aufnehmen. Nur so kurz. Wenn morgen alles gut läuft, dann sind wir morgen noch auf dem Comedypreis. Und man muss ganz ehrlich sagen, der Comedypreis war letztes Jahr der Grund dafür, dass wir das überhaupt alles machen.
Ohne den Comedypreis letztes Jahr, wo wir da rumgerannt sind, waren noch zwei Fremde, die aber sich in dieser Widerlichkeit dieser Veranstaltung gefunden haben.
Wollen wir morgen in der Sendung frühstücken?
Wollen wir hier frühstücken. Das war jetzt echt so ein Blick zwischen das ist das grösste Problem der Welt und es ist mir scheißegal. Aber wirklich eine 50-50 Mischung aus den beiden Emotionen. Ich habe erst gesagt, boah, das ist das grösste Problem der Welt, mache ich mir aber eigentlich scheiss drauf, Hamburg ist nur einmal im Jahr, dachte ich wieder. Ist das so das Motto für diese Reise gerade, Hamburg ist nur einmal im Jahr? Das ist so ein Gag, den du mir morgen klaust, wenn ich fest bin überzeugt. Hamburg ist nur einmal im Jahr? Warum soll ich den denn erwähnt? Weiß ich nicht. Hast du Angst, dass ich dir Gags klaue oder was? Warum denn?
Weil ich so wenig habe. Lass mir meine Gags in Ruhe. Ich habe doch nicht so viel.
Wo habe ich dir denn meinen Gag geklaut?
Ich bin mal vorgekommen. Und zwar bei der letzten Folge mit Ralf Rute. Da hast du so angefangen, einen Gag von mir zu klauen.
War das eine Überleitung?
Das ist ein großes Problem in meinem Leben, dass mir nie ein Beispiel einfällt. Das habe ich immer schon gehabt, auch in der Schule, wenn ich was erklären wollte und ich auch relativ genau wusste, warum das so ist, ist mir nie ein Beispiel eingefallen. Ich habe immer wahnsinnige Probleme, das passende Beispiel zu finden, was echt schwierig ist, wenn man was Moderatives macht, wo man die ganze Zeit sprechen muss. Ja, okay, aber das kann man ja üben. Ja, dann macht man Übung mit mir. Also was ist ein Beispiel für etwas, das am Anfang schlecht ist und dann immer besser wird? Twister. Erkläre. Auch mit Erklärungen. Ja klar, du kannst einfach random Worte sagen und denken, das geht als Lösung durch. Am Anfang denkt man noch so, ist das peinlich und so, aber irgendwann wird es immer spannender, weil immer die, am Anfang zum Beispiel, wenn man raus ist und sich das beobachten kann, wie die besten Freundinnen sich angrabschen plötzlich. Nein, aber am Anfang ist es langweilig, weil du musst halt nur eine Hand auf blau machen und so, denkst du, easy, und man wird zum Beispiel schwieriger und das wird immer lustiger und Leute lachen und fallen aufeinander. Was ist weiss und kann dennoch nicht fliegen?
Obwohl es weiss ist. Schon bei Prämissen im Spiel, die einfach sehr kritisch zu bewerten sind. Weiss, aber kann dennoch nicht fliegen. Eine tote weisse Möwe. Es auch nicht ist das Spiel halt. Oh, ich habe tatsächlich, ähm, äh, ich sammel jetzt, äh, Feetlines. Okay, das ist jetzt mein ... Wir machen jetzt mal ... Ich bin so in einer Gag-Stimmung jetzt, in so einer gackigen, klamaukigen Stimmung. Okay, ein paar Feetlines, die ich einfach raushauen und du musst sofort einfach einen Gag machen. Feetline, also die Punchline-Assoziationsspiel. Mhm. Eine Sache. Und? Okay, Feedline ist, ich will ja nicht angeben, aber... Mein Penis ist ziemlich klein. Okay. Man rechnet zumindest nicht damit. Ja. Zweitens, er starb bei seiner Lieblingsbeschäftigung.
Dem Twi... Und dann hört es auf.
Erkläre dich.
Beim Twittern halt, aber er stimmt währenddessen.
Und man sieht quasi live, während man den Tweet liest, er ist leider gestorben.
Ach, beim Twittern.
Ja, er passt halt nicht so richtig zu viel an. Aber er ist auch noch ein Assoziationsspiel, muss ja nicht perfekt sein.
Das ist Impro. Impro ist nie gut.
Was sind die drei grossen F eines guten Lebens?
Freundschaft,
Fleisch,
und Florentin. Ja, ein bisschen einfach. Was sind die drei grossen D einer erfolgreichen Beziehung? Dicke Möpse, dickes Auto und Dickmanns. Und Dickbach. Okay. Was, was, was sind die akzeptabel, zwei minus, keiner weiß warum. Was sind die drei grossen M eines katastrophalen Urlaubs? M und M's drei, okay, und Motten. Achso, das sind zwei Punkte, M&Ms. Motten, Motten und M&Ms. Aber ganz kurz bei ihm. War Motten bei dir mal irgendwann ein Thema? Never ever. Ich meine, das ist nicht so Thema im Sinne, das beschäftigt dich, aber... Aber ist eine sehr gute Frage. Aber ich hatte oft, als ich auf dem Land gewohnt habe, noch ... Ich hatte wahnsinnige Mottenprobleme. Also meine, oft wurden T-Shirts von mir einfach durchgebissen. Ich hatte in meinem Leben noch nie Mottenprobleme. Und ich verstehe auch nicht, was die Leute sagen. So Mottenkugeln und Kleidungsgefressen. Ja, aber ich habe noch nie jemanden getroffen, der Mottenprobleme hatte. Ich glaube, ich bin der einzige Mensch, der irgendwie, ich bin wie der König der Motten oder so ein Crab. Ich habe wahnsinnige Probleme damit. Was sind die drei grossen D der Mottenbekämpfung? Durchhaltevermögen, Donner bei Gewitter kommen sie nicht raus und dicke Brüste. Ja, richtig gut. Okay, was sind die ... Ich habe jetzt mal was für dich, und zwar
ist mir aufgefallen, dass es lustig ist, wenn man sich
von Comedy-CDs nur die Titel
durchliest, und zwar nicht die
Geschichten anhört und nicht die
Comedy-CDs anhört, sondern nur die
Titel sich anguckt, was sehr lustig ist, weil
die sich oft nicht erschliessen, wenn man den
Kontext nicht hat. Und zum Beispiel
vom Comedy auf der Titel S Skying and Viagra.
Skifahren und Viagra.
So, jetzt musst du dir die Geschichte ausdenken.
Ich muss dir die Geschichte ausdenken? Du musst drei Worte sagen mit einem Buchstaben und ich muss mir die ganze Geschichte ausdenken.
Wir tauchen ab, entspannt euch die nächsten eineinhalb Stunden.
Spart sich Florin in Will mit seiner Geschichte Skifahren und Viagra. Stefan Titzel hatte ausreichend gepackt für seinen Skiurlaub. Er hatte alles dabei, was er brauchte für ein entspannendes Wochenende auf der Alm. Aber er wollte natürlich auch Action haben, natürlich die Piste sollte es werden. Und Stefan Titzel natürlich, auch wenn man ihn davor gewarnt hatte, die schwarze Piste sollte es sein. Er schnallte sich also seine Ski an, setzte sich seinen Helm auf und merkte, er hat leider die Skistöcke vergessen. Doch da fiel ihm etwas ein, was ihm sein Vater noch kurz für die Abreise gegeben hat. Er sagte, mein Sohn, wenn du mal wieder Probleme mit dem Hörnchen in der Hose hast, nimm diese Viagra-Pillen! Und da wusste er, was zu tun war. Er würde diesen Abend bestreiten mit Ski und Viagra. Ich dachte jetzt, er nimmt die Viagra zu sich und benutzt sein erigiertes Glied als Skistock. Ja, das war ja die Implikation, was ich aber nicht ausgesprochen habe. Hättest du aussprechen müssen? Nein! Ich habe das jetzt verstanden, weil ich ein Comedy-Mastermind bin, aber die anderen Leute draußen vielleicht nicht. Ich glaube, die Leute haben es schon verstanden in dem Moment. Aber das ist tatsächlich ein ganz geiles Spiel. Und das hatte ich ja auch mal geplant, so wirklich einen Comedy-Podcast zu machen. Also nicht so ein Scheiß wie wir hier, sondern wirklich einen Podcast, in dem es nur um Comedy geht, wo man dann zum Beispiel auch so Spiele macht wie, man schreibt sich halt ein gesamtes Stand-Up-Programm, nur die Feedlines raus und überlegt dann, wie könnte der Gag weitergehen, was hat der Comedian draus gemacht, was macht man selber draus. Weil die Frage ist ja, was ist kreativ aufwendiger, die Feedline oder die Punchline?
Ist nicht die Idee schon in der Feedline drin?
Und wenn jemand mal sagt, so ich finde, Barbie-Puppen vermitteln ein falsches Bild der Realität, ist die Feedline, wie geht's weiter?
Ist da schon die geniale Idee drin, dass man daraus einen Gag machen kann, oder ist dann die Punchline, sie vermitteln ein falsches Bild, wie schwer es ist, jemandem den Kopf abzureissen, ist das dann die Punchline, der eigentliche kreative Effekt? Interessant, sollten wir vielleicht auch machen. Aber das finde ich auch gut, dann zum Beispiel auch so bei Mario Bart oder so, da mal gucken, die Feedline sich anhören und gucken, ob man das antizipieren kann. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich habe mit meinem Mitbewohner früher oft so diese Sechserpack und diese Dreier-WG, so dieses Sat-1-Sketch-Dinge angeguckt. Und wir haben ein Spiel draus gemacht, dass wir uns ein Sketch angeguckt haben und wer zuerst wusste, was die Pointe ist, der hat gewonnen, halt Pointenraten einfach. Und du bist unglaublich erstaunt, wie oft du richtig liegst. Echt? Also nach ein... Dadurch, daran, dass ich halt euch schon mit Comedy beschäftigt habe, und wüsst, wie es funktioniert, oder? Am Anfang tappt man noch im Dunkeln, aber wenn man mal so ein, zwei Folgen gesehen hat, dann hat man wirklich eine 80-prozentige Quote. Aber was heißt das denn, wenn du das erraten kannst? Heißt es, dass der kreative Prozess zu einem gewissen Prozentsatz schon in der Feedline steckt, oder dass du genauso gut bist wie diese Comedy-Autorin, die das geschrieben haben? Nee, es ist immer, es ist immer, also es ist oft, es wird eine Situation gezeigt, die erst normal scheint und dann bildlich gesehen zoomt die Kamera raus und es wird eine neue Situation präsentiert, die alles ins Absurde bringt. Also meinetwegen reden zwei Menschen über ihr Kind, Futter und Martha reden über ihr Kind und sagen, er hat so viel Scheisse gebaut in der Schule und so, was ist denn los? Man zoomt raus, es ist ein Hund, um jetzt mal an Comedy-Klassiker auszupacken. So was, ne? Und das ist das Schema, das du tatsächlich ganz einfach antizipieren kannst, oder so was, ne? Die Leute reden über, was du denkst, ist Sex, also sie liegen zum Beispiel zusammen im Bett und der Mann auf der Frau und sie reden über etwas, also sexuelle Anspielungen, aber dann zoomen sie raus und sie liegen im Ikea und sie haben eigentlich nur über das Preis gesprochen oder halt irgend so was. Preisabfall. Und halt so was von wegen, komm nicht zu früh im Sinne von dein Auto steht noch, ach ich hab keine Ahnung. Das ist auch was, was Leute beim Sex ständig sagen, komm nicht zu früh. Das ist meine das ist, wo meine Angst auch gut rüberkommt. Komm nicht wieder zu früh. Was sind Dinge, die Leute beim Sex sagen? Die Frau sagt, bitte komm nicht zu früh, die ganze Zeit. Dirty talk, ne? Können wir auch einen guten Tweet machen eigentlich. Also nicht, ich liebe es, wenn meine... Nicht schon wieder, bitte lass nicht mal meine Brille außen vor. Ja, ich liebe es, wenn meine Frau so sexy Sachen sagt, wie bitte, bitte komm nicht zu früh. Ja, das ist nicht so blöd. Ja. Finde ich gut. Ja, ich würde sagen, wir wissen, haben jetzt einen Plan, was wir morgen machen. Absolut. Und ich hoffe, ihr seid live dabei. Also nicht im Ansatz, dass ihr das davor überhaupt hören könnt. Von daher. Da müssen wir jetzt noch schneiden. Ah, wir werden heute Nacht noch schneiden. Aber unsere Seelen aneinanderschneiden. Heute werden einige Grenzen überschritten, Stefan Titzel. Das war auf gar keiner Ebene irgendwie in der Metapher geblieben. Es war einfach irgendwas gesagt. Also, schön, dass ihr dabei wart bei dieser neuen Folge. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart, vielen Dank, dass ihr uns hört. Und diese Folge geht natürlich auch raus an die Leute, die dafür gespendet haben, dass wir heute mal die Möglichkeit haben. Ja, alle anderen können die aber auch hören, was es für ein dummer Aussage. Ja, aber die können sich jetzt innerlich bedanken bei Jonas und Karin und Manfred und Jochen, die alle dafür gespendet haben, dass diese Folge heute möglich ist. Du hast sogar zwei getroffen, glaube ich, in der Tat. Ich kenne die Namen mittlerweile, ich habe alle nämlich das Geld wieder zurücküberwiesen,
ich kenne die Namen in und auswendig, ich habe ganz auf die Beträge nochmal gecheckt.
Vielen Dank an Jonas, vielen Dank an Frederik. Und jetzt verbringen wir den Abend mit unserer eine Stunde kostenloses Internet,
was uns das Hotel gnädig gereicht hat.
Internet kostet neun Euro die Stunde.
Du, mir würde fünf Minuten kostenloses Internet gerade reichen, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht.
Neun Euro die Stunde kostet, wenn nicht hier was eine absolute Frechheit ist, aber die erste Stunde kriegt man.
Ja, da haben sie einen Haken. Das sind Schweine.
Macht's gut, tschüss.